die 11 köpfige kommission aus
kolleginnen und kollegen aus österreich
und deutschland aus verschiedensten
wissenschaftsbereichen hatte die aufgabe
die öffentlich zugänglichen flächen des
heeresgeschichtlichen museums zu
überprüfen sie haben auch die planzahl
halle im areal des arsenals mit
überprüfte muss die kolleginnen kollegen
der kommission natürlich entschuldigen
wir haben natürlich auch heute gerne
gekommen ist aber pandemie bedingt nicht
möglich gewesen
vorausschicken möchte ich auch nachdem
diese diskussion vor über einem jahr ja
ich ein auslöser der überprüfung war
dass wir keine betone keine hinweise auf
antisemitische rassistische oder
rechtsextreme inhalte gefunden haben
auch wenn vielleicht die fehler in
kontexte bei einzelnen objekt gruppen
spielraum zur interpretation geben
vorweg schicken möchte ich auch dass die
kommission zu keinem zeitpunkt ihrer
prüfung zweifel an der notwendigkeit
oder der existenz des jahres
geschichtlichen museums geübt hat das
sind uns alle bewusst dass das
geschichtliche museum über eine
international vor allem mitteleuropäisch
hervorragende sammlung verfügt die es
auch entsprechend zu präsentieren gilt
präsentiert wird diese sammlung zur zeit
ja im ältesten museumsbau wiens meiner
frühen architektur von theophil hansen
der quasi die seinerzeit den
seinerzeitigen leitgedanken es ging ja
sehr um ruhm und ehre des hauses
habsburg auch quasi in stein gegossen
hat das heißt das objekt selbst ist er
vielleicht schon das erste museums
objekt und die diesem gebäude finden wir
eine sehr heterogene situationen
dauerausstellungen die von den
neunzigern 50er jahren herauf bis in die
20er jahre entstanden sind und wo man
sich immer wieder fragen muss oder auch
ich mich immer wieder gefragt habe wie
sie ja ist es
der nachfolgende generationen gelungen
sich von diesem ursprünglichen
gründungsgedanken von diesem konzept des
habsburgischen waffen museums zu lösen
ich glaube es ist auch wichtig zu
betonen dass es sich beim
heeresgeschichtlichen museum um die
einzige ausstellung im bundesbereich
handelt wo man die geschichte des
habsburgerreiches vom 16 17 jahrhundert
bis zu seinem ende und natürlich auch
dann die folgejahre präsentiert bekommt
natürlich primär aus einer
militärhistorischen perspektive aber
seien wir uns bewusst militärs deutscher
perspektive ist immer mit der
politischen geschichte verbunden und von
dies auch nicht so trainern daher hat
dieses haus auch aus meiner sicht eine
besondere verantwortung wenn es darum
geht wie in diesem haus geschichte
vermittelt wird in diesem bericht finden
sie zahlreiche das immer für die
fotografen ja finden sie zahlreiche
anregungen der kommission es ist uns als
kommission bewusst dass man nicht alle
diese anregungen auch entsprechend
aufnehmen und umsetzen wird etwas anders
kommission einfach wichtig zu zeigen die
große bandbreite an möglichkeiten die es
in diesem haus auch gibt natürlich immer
nur wenn es die entsprechenden
rahmenbedingungen für diese umsetzung
auch geben sollte die rahmenbedingungen
sind natürlich auch eine problemstellung
weil seien wir uns ehrlich wenn wir das
jahres geschichtliche museum besuchen so
ist augenscheinlich dass es hier einen
über jahrzehnte gewachsenen
investitionsrückstau gibt sowohl am
gebäude als auch bei den ausstellungen
selbst wobei annehme und ist auch den
kollegen früherer generationen zugute
halten dass sie sich sicherlich bemüht
haben im rahmen ihrer möglichkeiten sich
so gut wie möglich zu helfen wenn sie im
anschluss daran dann den bericht lesen
wir haben kann ich vorweg schicken es
gibt einen kurzen executive summary der
den journalisten journalisten denn das
leben vielleicht ein wenig ein
sache machen wird ich möchte so die die
wichtigsten punkte unserer unseres
berichts ein wenig hervorheben dass sie
nochmal punktet immer positiv
hervorheben muss positiv aus unserer
sicht ist sicherlich der
ausstellungsteil zum ersten weltkrieg so
bewerten der ja aus dem jahr 2014
präsentiert wurde und er sich natürlich
im vergleich zu den früheren älteren
ausstellungsteil sehr positiv abhebt von
seiner ausstellungsgestaltung aber auch
von seinem inhaltlichen zugang sehr
positiv zu bemerken ist auch die arbeit
und das angebot der vermittlung im
heeresgeschichtlichen museum was auch
wichtig ist nach dem sehr viele
schülerinnen und schüler dieses haus
auch nützen
und ja wir müssen uns auch den
kolleginnen und kollegen zu gute halten
dass es ihnen gelungen ist durch ein
veranstaltungsprogramm ein dichtes
veranstaltungsprogramm der letzten jahre
die besuchszahlen zu steigern wie wohl
wird die qualität dieser veranstaltungen
nicht überprüft haben weil ihm über
prüfungszeitraum auch keine
veranstaltungen möglich gewesen sind was
sie die kommission jetzt kritisch und
leider ist ein größerer teil kritisch zu
sehen
die kommission sieht es als kritisch an
dass die ansprüche eines modernen
militärgeschichte museums in weiten
teilen fehlern
was das heißt bekomme ich vielleicht
später noch darauf zu sprechen
es fehlt auch die dimension des kriegers
die zerstörerische dimension die
massiven gesellschaftlichen konsequenzen
eines griechische dimensionen der gewalt
ist eine problemstellung für museen
generell das in museen der krieg immer
sehr geordnet strukturiert bereinigt und
daher auch in einem gewissen sinne
verschönt und verharmlost
die kommission kritisiert dass ein
gesamtkonzept nicht erkennbar ist das
ist stückwerk über jahrzehnte
gewachsenes stückwerk und in vielen
bereichen
es fehlt ein narrativ oder das narrativ
nur sehr schwer zu entschlüsseln
es ist in vielen bereichen ein museum
von fachexpertinnen und fachexperten für
ein fachpublikum in vielen teilen zeigen
die ausstellungen des den charakter
eines depots über eine überfülle an
objekten ohne entsprechende
kontextualisierung ohne entsprechende
erklärungen was wir auch bemängelt das
ist das eine
traditionspflege eine zeitgemäße
traditionspflege auch im hgm nicht
erkennbar ist jetzt muss man sagen ja
für die traditionspflege sind bin jetzt
nicht so der experte sind auch andere
instanzen innerhalb des bundesheeres
notwendig aber wenn wir uns gerade als
vergleich die traditionspflege der
deutschen bundeswehr heranziehen die ein
ähnliches schicksal hat oder ähnliche
problemstellungen mit ihrer
vergangenheit dann sind es die
revolution von 1848 dann ist das der
widerstand des militärs in zeiten des
nationalsozialismus dann ist sozusagen
der schutz demokratische grundordnung
als das sind die die säulen und wenn man
es her ist geschichtlich muss sich
umschauen und wir blicken beispielsweise
aus jahr 1848 dann fahren eigentlich
nichts darüber wieso sich hier eine
bevölkerung wieso sich die bürgerinnen
und bürger erhoben haben sondern wir
hören was von aufständischen rebellion
diaz siegreich zu schlagen gilt
überhaupt dieses glorreiche so eines der
hauptthemen das sich durch dieses haus
zieht in vielen bereichen geht es von
der architektur ja schon beginnend um
ruhm und ehre und gloria des hauses
habsburg und seiner heerführer im
gebäude in den sammlungen und auch in
vielen ausstellungsteile wo man eher
unkritisch und verklärt
hierfür darstellt von wallenstein über
prinz gehen
lokal bis hin zu radetzky und hüttendorf
und das ist natürlich gerade dann
problematisch wenn diese glorreichen
siegreichen feldherren gegen die eigene
bevölkerung eingesetzt wurden
generell generell überstrahlen und wie
gesagt das ist ja schon der grundgedanke
des 19 jahrhunderts die sieger
überstrahlen alles
die niederlagen die ursachen die gegner
bleiben vielfach im dunkeln und wenn sie
auftreten die gegner beispielsweise des
osmanischen reichs dann treten sie als
beutestücke auf die man quasi als
siegestrophäe präsentiert hat man könnte
auch die vermutung anstellen dass es vor
allem den dort tätigen kolleginnen und
kollegen nach 1945 schon ein anliegen
gewesen ist nach den brüchen der ersten
hälfte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts hier
einen positiven anschluss eine
glorreiche geschichte des
habsburgerreiches und damit einen
beitrag zu einem österreichischen
identitätsstiftung herzustellen
natürlich sind von der sammlung hier
es ist ja schon eine sehr alte sammlung
da finden wir natürlich die zilien aus
dem hause habsburg wir finden nachlässe
der großen feldherrn der offiziere
befinden wenig vom einfachen soldaten
die geschichte des militärs wird quasi
vom feldherrnhügel aus präsentiert man
hat den eindruck es geht um die
feierliche erinnerung an feldherren und
nicht um die darstellung ihrer daten und
schon gar nicht um einen differenzierten
blick auf ihre karrieren überhaupt
dieser blick ist so ein thema multi
perspektive fehlt eigentlich ist eine
sehr einseitige form der darstellung es
fehlt die multi perspektive innerhalb
des militärs wie gesagt bis hin zum
einfachen soldaten es fehlen die frage
so händler
fragen natürlich ebenso auch wenn
natürlich im österreichischen bundesheer
soldaten erst ab 1998 tätig gewesen sind
und es fehlt natürlich auch der blick
der gesellschaft der zivilbevölkerung
der unbeteiligten an den kriegerischen
auseinandersetzungen
vielfach werden auch vereint bilder
fortgeschrieben und radiert besonders
erkennbar im bereich des osmanischen
reichs und auch hier finden wir gerade
auch viele grafiken die den gegner
verunglimpfen die sich über den lustig
machen oder die ihn sozusagen in seinem
schrecken über höhen aus
propagandistischen gründen auch das
gehört gehörte wie gesagt erklärt hat
auch den eindruck wenn man durchs
geschichtliche museum geht es kriege
bestehen hauptsächlich aus waffen und
gemälden
es werden sehr viele gemälde eingesetzt
um sozusagen jetzt die schlacht
darzustellen dabei finde ich aber keine
erklärungen dazu dass diese gemälde aus
generationen später entstanden sind dass
sie oft aus politischen
propagandistischen gründen heraus
entstanden sind nun natürlich nicht
spiegelbild einer wirklichkeit gewesen
sind das erdgeschichtliche museum bietet
auch sehr wenig anknüpfungspunkte an die
gegenwart und die zukunft was eigentlich
auch mittlerweile ein großer auftrag
eines museums sein sollte die letzten 30
jahre der geschichte des bundesheeres
beispielsweise fehlen also die
darstellung endet noch 1 10 91
und ja auch diese präsentation der
geschichte des österreichischen
bundesheers von 19 55 bis 91 in einem
zelt hinter dem gebäude wo man es nicht
weiß ist dass ein provisorium oder ist
das doch schon eine längerfristige
lösung ja hier finden wir eine
zeitgemäße ausstellungsgestaltung auch
das narrativ ist erkennbar
aber gerade in diesem bereich muss man
sagen es hat schon sehr stark den
charakter einer diaschau des
österreichischen bundesheer also eine
ausstellung die man sich wahrscheinlich
eher am 26 oktober am heldenplatz
erwarten würde und nicht in einem museum
das natürlich auch kritisch auf diese
fragen zu geben muss da ist dann muss
man sozusagen auch kritik üben dürfen da
kann man nicht so wie dieser ausstellung
die habe broschüren nur des bundesheeres
sozusagen darstellen und nur strahlende
und glückliche soldaten
auch wenn es die auch geben sollte
schließlich ja auch nicht aus aber wir
immer selbst auch mal die möglichkeit
hatte das zu erleben weiß ja dass es
nicht immer nur glücklich was wir auch
sehr stark kritisieren das
erdgeschichtliche museum verfügt über
7300 quadratmeter ausstellungsfläche die
dort verantwortlichen wir uns sagen es
ist zu wenig weil sie könnten noch viel
mehr spielen das ist eine riesige fläche
das ist so groß wie es deutsche
historische museum oder zehnmal so groß
das haus der geschichte österreichs bei
dieser gesamtfläche ist nicht einmal ein
prozent ein prozent 115 quadratmeter
sind eine sonderausstellungsfläche jetzt
kann man natürlich sagen ja nicht jedes
museum muss auch eine sonderausstellung
präsentiert aber das sind ja die
möglichkeiten für uns im museum aktuelle
themen kritisch zeitgemäß aufzuarbeiten
die dann nicht wieder für die nächsten
10 oder 20 jahre so stehen bleiben
müssen und zum teil gibt es auch einen
offensichtlichen konservatorischen
handlungsbedarf der ist sozusagen bei
einzelnen objekten die dort ausgestellt
sind auch erkennbar ob das das raumklima
anbelangt oder das ungefiltert
eintreffende tageslicht so was empfiehlt
die kommission die kommission empfiehlt
dem ministerium der frau
bundesministerin einen strategieprozess
einzuleiten hin zu einem gesamtkonzept
das ist vielleicht nichts neues auch der
bundesrechnungshof hat das schon
angemerkt ein gesamtkonzept das eben
einen inhaltlichen teil in sich trägt
wie gehe ich mit meinen sachen wie
sollen sich die sammlungen
weiterentwickeln die soll sich die
ausstellung weiterentwickeln aber
vielleicht auch einen organisatorisch
infrastrukturen
teil in sich trägt weil das müssen wir
schon betonen dass es das einzige museum
in österreich des bundes das noch als
nachgeordnete dienststelle auch geführt
wird
dieses gesamtkonzept und da sind ja hier
jetzt wieder als inhaltliche gruppe sehr
stark gefragt gewesen hier geht es
natürlich um eine neukonzeption des
museums also wir glauben nicht dass man
die jetzige bisherige strategie
fortsetzen sollte und wieder jede
generation macht halt 21
im prinzip war dann wird sich diese
situation zum zur unzufriedenheit aller
verlängern und das ist ja auch jetzt der
frau bundesministerin so beim herein
gegen gesagt wenn wir uns ehrlich sind
ist ja keiner mit diesem museum
zufrieden
es gibt menschen die müssen von ihrer
professor von ihrer position her damit
offiziell zufrieden sein sowie ein
direkter aber wenn man sich rundherum
umhört muss man sagen es gibt eigentlich
kaum positive stimmen
und ja das spricht natürlich für eine
neukonzeption des museums grund der
dauerausstellung inklusive einer
generalsanierung um ein zeitgemäßes
militärhistorisches museum europäischer
dimension zu schaffen was diese sammlung
und ist das haus auch verdient was ist
das für ein museum das ist dann ein
museum für eine gesamte gesellschaft es
ist ein museum das sich mit der
bedeutung des militärs und des her
wesens im laufe der geschichte außer
machen das jetzt immer im kontext der
allgemeinen geschichte sein muss sich um
das den bedeutungswandel darstellt die
wechselbeziehungen des militärs hin zu
den verfassungsrechtlichen politischen
wirtschaftlichen sozialen kulturellen
rahmenbedingungen und lebensbereichen
dass ein museum das sich mit den
ursachen den kontexten und den folgen
militärischer konflikte auseinandersetzt
mit der frage von gewalt als mittel der
ausübung von herrschaft mit der frage
der legitimität militärischer
gewaltanwendung mit den verschiedensten
formen von konflikten mit der
schutzfunktion des heeres seiner
bedeutung als ordnungsmacht bis hin zum
schutz
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
denken wir nur zurück sechster jänner
capitol washington die frage wo ist das
militär wo es die nationalgarde es ist
ein museum dass ich mit sicherheit im
weitesten sinne beschäftigen und es geht
ihm um die militärische die bewaffnete
macht als eine politische kraft als ein
instrument und ein mittel der politik es
geht um dessen führung in krieg und
frieden es geht nicht nur um das militär
als institution sondern als teil der
gesamten gesellschaft der
wirtschaftlichen der gesellschaftlichen
des öffentlichen lebens es geht vor
allem auch um den einfachen soldaten den
haben wir quasi in diesem haus überhaupt
vermisst der einfache soldat in allen
lebensbereichen so wie wir auch die von
den konflikten betroffene
zivilbevölkerung vermisst haben es geht
um eine jahrhundertelange gewalt
geschichte militärische konflikte sind
immer eine gewalt geschichte es geht um
die darstellung auch von gewalt und der
authentizität des krieges wir müssen
sagen das darstellen von geworden
das war so viel gemalt ja die
darstellung von gewalt und krieg ist ja
etwas was nicht darstellbar ist es geht
um das ausstellen das eigentlich nicht
aussterben aber es braucht diese
darstellung von gewalt von verzweiflung
von angst und leid und es braucht auch
objekte die die spuren des krieges in
sich tragen es können nicht immer nur
restaurierte schöne funkelnde bunter
objekte seien
bevor das redog vulkans zusammenfällt
also was empfiehlt die kommission noch
ja auch diese diese möglichkeit diesen
zeitraum jetzt so nutzer vielleicht für
eine kritische reflexion der strukturen
wir bringen beispiele für einen verbleib
oder nicht verbleib innerhalb des
ressorts von bundesministern hat er da
schon eine dezidierte meinung dass auch
immer schon geäußert hat und ja es geht
darum das natürlich dass
heeresgeschichtlichen museum nach dem
forschungs organisationsgesetz
eigentlich weisungsfrei gestellt ist
aber es ist natürlich schauen die frage
wie diese inhaltlich autonom ist hier
ein führungsteam im haus tatsächlich wie
kritisch kann man sicher beispielsweise
die darstellung der geschichte des
bundesheers auch tatsächlich innerhalb
dieses geschoss sein dazu braucht es
auch ein gutes team ein starkes team die
arbeit muss er von einem team erfolgen
dem team des hauses dass wir als
kommission stärker interdisziplinär
aufgestellt gesehen hätten
also da braucht es nicht nur die jetzige
militärhistorische waffen technische
expertise da braucht es auch zusätzliche
expertise anderer wissenschaftlicher
disziplinen und ja die kommission
empfiehlt diesen prozess dann auch von
einem wissenschaftlichen beirat so wie
es beispielsweise auf dem haus der
geschichte österreichs auch gegeben ist
begleiten zu lassen und nicht zuletzt
wünscht sich die kommission auch eine
stärkere noch stärkere abstimmung des
jahres geschichtliche museums mit
anderen museen in österreich die in
diesem bereich tätig sind ja in diesem
sinn zu sagen so wird der kurze
durchgang ich darf jetzt offizieller
verbunden
den bericht über leichen sehr geehrte
damen und herren fährt der präsident
muss seit ich in diesem haus die führung
übernommen habe begleitet mich ein wort
um sie als auch verwendet
investitionsrückstau in so vielen
bereichen
es begleitet mich ist begleitet uns auch
die thematik im heeresgeschichtlichen
museum seit dieser zeit
und seit ich hier bin seitdem sind wir
bemüht nicht nur einen überblick über
die diversen herausforderungen im
bereich der verwaltung und der musealen
bereich zu bekommen sondern diesen
schrittweise auch in eine positive
zukunft zu führen
immer wieder gibt es dazu auch austausch
mit der zuständigen auch
staatssekretärin meyer mit dem kultur
sprecherinnen und unser blick ist
geschärft worden
zum einen durch den rechnungshofbericht
und zum anderen herr präsident durch die
beiden kommissionsbericht und ich
persönlich bin der meinung dass wir nun
in die zukunft blicken können gemeinsam
und veränderung voranbringen können
ich möchte mich hier an dieser stelle
bedanken ich möchte die gelegenheit
nutzen um ihnen sehr geehrter herr
präsident danke zu sagen stellvertretend
für ihr team das aus nationalen und
internationalen experten und expertinnen
besteht danke für diese hier vorgelegte
arbeit
ich glaube diese ist beispiellos und sie
wird bestimmt zum vorbild für die
betrachtung etlicher anderer museen
werden was mir was uns auch wichtig ist
das haben wir im vorfeld auch besprochen
ist dass dieser bericht umgehend der
öffentlichkeit auch digital zugänglich
gemacht werden wird
das bild das uns dieser bericht zeigt
auch unter berücksichtigung der beiden
anderen berichte
das ist das bild eines
renovierungsbedürftigen hauses
renovierungsbedürftige auf der
wissenschaftlichen ebene aber auch auf
der verwaltungsebene es gibt viel zu tun
und dennoch ist eines festzuhalten dass
dieser bericht vor allem auch wege und
eine bandbreite sowie sie gesagt haben
herr präsident in die zukunft aufzeigt
der bericht beinhaltet 23 mal die worte
chance und möglichkeit unter er
beinhaltet auch positive dinge die vom
herrn präsident schon angesprochen
worden sind zum beispiel leben
die besucherzahlen die gesteigert werden
konnten
zum zweiten ist vielleicht schon auch
festzuhalten dass sehr viele sind die
jahre 55 zurück geht auch sehr viele der
verfehlungen dorthin zurückgehen es ist
nicht so dass alle fehler in den letzten
jahren passiert sind aber
nichtsdestotrotz haben wir viele
baustellen und setzen nun erste
maßnahmen
wir haben im vorfeld besprochen viele
der anregungen im bericht umzusetzen es
wird daher umgehend erstens unter der
führung von miram präsidenten dr muhic
ein ständiger wissenschaftlicher beirat
für das ag eingerichtet werden der die
künftige führung des museums auf
wissenschaftlicher ebene beraten soll
vielen dank an dieser stelle auch dafür
zweitens es werden beginnend mit einer
ersten finanzspritze von 4,3 millionen
euro adaptierungen an den ausstellungen
vorgenommen werden es geht dabei um
modernisierung und digitalisierung
drittens im bereich der führung ist
derzeit die erstellung der direktoren
ausschreibung in arbeit und auch hier
wollen wir über neue zugänge
geschlagen nachdenken wir prüfen derzeit
die zusätzliche implementierung einer
verwaltungseinheit in der führung nah
und viertens wohl der wichtigste punkt
wir werden mit der künftigen führung des
museums ein gesamtkonzept für das museum
erstellen erstellen müssen und dies
abschliessend abarbeiten das
heeresgeschichtlichen museum übernimmt
für österreich und seine bevölkerung
eine große verantwortung
dieses museum soll uns neben der reinen
und reichen militärgeschichte unter
militär kultur dieses landes nämlich
auch die schrecken von krieg und gewalt
zeigen damit jeder mensch der das museum
besucht weiß kriege gehören ins museum
dankeschön werte medienvertreter haben
sie fragen
bitte schön wenn sie kurz warten ihrem
medium nennen und dann die frage stellen
dankeschön stefan weis vom standard frau
ministerin sie wollen jetzt die leitung
des museums neu ausschreiben
heißt das auch dass der amtierende
direktor abgelöst werden soll oder wird
in die chance geboten sich erneut zu
bewerben
was sind jetzt die nächsten schritte was
die direktoren ausschreibung anbelangt
wir wollten neben die vollständigen
berichte abwarten rechnungshofbericht
und jetzt auch dieser zweite bericht der
kommission von präsident bush
ich habe angeordnet dass dann nach dem
gespräch mit dem bms dass wir dazu ja
auch brauchen die ausschreibung so bald
wie möglich durchzuführen ist ich habe
an dieser stelle aber auch wir haben
dazu auch im haus unsere hausaufgaben zu
erledigen was die vorbereitung eben
dieser ausschreibung anbelangt hier muss
in jeden fall qualität vor schnelligkeit
gehen was die ausschreibung anbelangt
weil er insbesondere eine
gesamtkonzeption und so ist das auch im
bericht vorgeschlagen bedingt dass diese
im team der führung auch zu machen ist
selbstverständlich kann sich hier jeder
bewerben das ist steht ja außer außer
frage
dankeschön gibt es weitere fragen aus
dem plenum bitteschön martin fichter was
von der austria presse agentur
können sie es trotzdem etwas
spezifizieren wollen sie die
ausschreibung noch möglichst im ersten
halbjahr machen perspektive wenn man bei
den zeit fragen sind die 4,3 millionen
finanzspritze gibt es für heuer oder was
wäre da der zeitraum also zum ersten
teil der frage tatsächlich so schnell
wie möglich wir brauchen ja insbesondere
aber auch für die frage der bewertung
des direktorenpostens ein zweites
ressort dazu sobald diese gespräche
abgeschlossen sind und ich hoffe jedoch
dass das zeitnah im ersten halbjahr auch
der fall sein kann die mitarbeiter eines
zweiten ressorts ich habe bewusst die
4,3 millionen euro seine eine erste
finanzspritze genannt weil wir sehen ja
hier dass es sehr vieles andere auch
noch bedarf und sowie bei der umsetzung
der 90 empfehlungen des rechnungshofes
eines nach dem anderen zu tun ist und
wird das auch hier notwendig sein das
kann nur ein erster schritt sein
dem viele andere folgen werden und
müssen ja was bitte noch einmal
wie soll der wissenschaftliche beirat
genau aufgestellt werden kann sich aber
ermutigt die personen selbst aussuchen
oder in welchen zusammenspiel wird diese
aufstellung passieren wir haben mehr für
den wissenschaftlichen beirats um einen
einmal eine richtschnur im gesetzlichen
bereich weil es ja in unseren
vorgesprächen auch darum gegangen ist
dass es nach dem paragrafen 8 glaube ich
wenn ich es richtig im kopf hat das
bundesministerium gesetzes gestaltet
werden soll
ich bin an dieser stelle sehr froh dass
er präsident moser diesem beirat
vorstehen wird und bin überzeugt davon
dass nationale und international
alle experten hier mit einbeziehen wird
und das werden wir in gemeinsamen guten
gesprächen tun vielleicht man keine
frage sie haben relativ wenig gesagt zum
zum ort des hgm als ort der
traditionspflege des bundesheers
repräsentations bühne unter
anführungszeichen für das heer
wie wollen sie denn das neu aufstehen
neu denken
ich glaube sehr vieles ist ja dem
bericht zu entnehmen dass in die in die
zukunft weist es soll ein museum werden
das dem heutigen stand von wissenschaft
und logie entspricht es soll ein profil
entwickeln auf höhe der zeit und
inhaltlich wird uns mit sicherheit hier
der wissenschaftliche beirat der dass er
schon in seinen beiden gerichten getan
hat vieles an grundlagen auch bieten ein
museum für das bundesheer aber nicht nur
für das bundesheer sondern für die
gesamte gesellschaft so viel in aller
kürze das andere ist aber dann zu
erarbeiten in einem gesamtkonzept
wir hatten medienvertreter wenn es keine
weiteren fragen gibt dann beende ich die
pressekonferenz zum bericht des
heeresgeschichtlichen museums ich danke
für kommen